president trump is deepening the threat
of a constitutional crisis
after the november election he has
refused to promise that he'll leave
office peacefully if defeated ben tracy
reports on the president's
most direct challenge yet to the
legitimacy
of the vote will you commit to making
sure that there is a peaceful transferal
of power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster president trump has not
provided any evidence to support his
ballot claims
he also suggested getting rid of mail-in
ballots
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
this isn't the first time the president
has said he may not accept the results
if he loses
it's a rigged election it's the only way
we're going to lose last night former
vice president joe biden blasted the
president
what country are we in look uh
he says the most irrational things i
i don't know what to say about but it
doesn't surprise me president trump is
also once again at odds with his own
health experts
hours after fda commissioner stephen
hahn tried to reassure the public
that approval of a vaccine won't be
rushed science
will guide our decisions fda will not
permit any pressure
from anyone to change that president
trump who has said a vaccine could be
ready by election day
claimed the white house will have the
final say we're going to look at it
we're going to take a look at it and
ultimately the white house has to
approve it
campaigning in the battleground state of
north carolina wednesday
biden also criticized the president's
recent claim that virtually nobody
except
older americans is dying of coronavirus
so you go home and your mom's gone your
dad's gone
he's a virtual nobody the white house is
denying reports that dr
deborah burks the coordinator of the
white house coronavirus task force has
been sidelined in favor of the
president's hand-picked doctor
scott atlas but cbs news has learned
that dr burks and other members of the
task force
have clashed with atlas who has
questioned the use of masks
and called school closures hysteria
anthony
ben thank you